If there's one thing that the Harry
Potter movies did exceptionally well,
it was casting the right actors for the
series' many substantial roles. Despite
the intimidating number of memorable characters
featured throughout the original Potter books,
the films always consistently managed to
cast talented actors who were ultimately
well-suited to their roles. That wasn't just
the case with the series' older figures either,
many of whom were played by legendary British
stage and screen actors, but also with its
younger characters. Emma Watson, Rupert Grint,
and Daniel Radcliffe, for instance, were all
cast at young ages to play the franchise's
central trio, and the three actors grew into
talented screen performers over the course of
the series' eight film installments. Each of
the three have gone on to have successful acting
careers outside of the Potter franchise as well.
However, the Harry Potter franchise ended up
having to recast a handful of roles across its
eight installments. In fact, fans may be surprised
to learn that, in the case of Lavender Brown,
the memorable character ended up being
played by a total of three different actors.
Though she's not credited, actor Kathleen Cauley
originally played Lavender Brown in 2002's Harry
Potter and the Chamber of Secrets. Two years
later, in 2004's Harry Potter and the Prisoner
of Azkaban, the character was played by Jennifer
Smith, who had no lines but appeared in the
background a handful of times throughout the film.
When Lavender became a major character in Harry
Potter and the Half-Blood Prince, though, she
was played by Jessie Cave. She went on to reprise
the role two more times in Harry Potter and the
Deathly Hallows Part 1 and in its 2011 follow-up,
Deathly Hallows Part 2. Many have often wondered
why the role was played by three different
actors in the Potter films, but the folks at
Fandom think the explanation is pretty clear.
As they tell it, the Harry Potter and the
Half-Blood Prince novel, which makes Lavender a
major character for the first time, was released
in July 2005 after both the Chamber of Secrets
and Prisoner of Azkaban films were made. That
means that, at the time of their release,
the teams behind those two films didn't know that
Lavender would be a major character in the future.
Therefore, they likely just assigned the character
name to Cauley and Smith in the Chamber of Secrets
and Azkaban films to help better organize
those films' various background players.
ScreenRant theorizes that since Lavender's
profile rose in the sixth installment,
the producers went with a more
established actor in Cave.
Yet these explanations haven't stopped fans
from raising concerns about the recasting.
Harry Potter film fans know that the Lavender
Brown character grew in her impact on the
overall storyline in the sixth movie when
she became a love interest for Ron Weasley
following his triumphant first match
as the Gryffindor quidditch keeper.
As chants of "Weasley" echo in the Gryffindor
common room, Jessie Cave's Lavender Brown
rushes in and starts making out with Ron. What
those who've not read the books may not realize
is that the snogging was described as being
"impossible to tell whose hands were whose."
“Lovely.”
That might sound like a bit much for a young
adult franchise, but some have taken it literally
as an indication that Lavender and Ron have the
same skin color, though it's entirely possible
the passage was meant figuratively to simply
describe how intense the cuddle session was.
Regardless of how one interprets that particular
line, it's indisputable that Lavender was first
played by two Black actors when the character had
no lines and was recast with a white actor when
the character took on a larger role in Half-Blood
Prince. Off Colour said it’s worth pointing out,
"The tone-deafness of recasting a role
that had been played by two Black actresses
with a white actress as soon as
the character is given a line.”
They concluded,
"[The recasting was] especially bad
since Harry Potter doesn't accurately
represent Britain's great diversity."
Check out one of our newest
videos right here! Plus,
even more Looper videos about your
favorite movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one.